Like many of you,
I'm very curious about the future of
blockchain and how it might integrate into
various frameworks of our society.
Uh,
and for that we have a
very special guest today,
Dr Tonika Tillaman.
Uh,
Dr Tillaman is the chairman of the
global blockchain business council.
He's a co founder of the
blockchain trust accelerator.
He is a member of the advisory
board of the bid fury group,
which is a leading food service
blockchain company. Great. So, um,
I'm sure most of you guys are
already familiar with blockchain and
cryptocurrencies. Uh, but the Mica,
can you please just very
briefly explain those concepts?
Absolutely.
And I should clarify that I spend most
of my time explaining these concepts to
audiences that maybe spend a lot of time
working on high level policy issues or
a c level executives in big corporations,
but don't know that much about technology.
I realized that is not the case today.
So I am thrilled to have an audience
here that I'm sure we'll have incredible
insights on the technical aspects of
this technology beyond some of the policy
and business, uh, components that
we're going to discuss today.
Block chain at its core is just a record.
It's,
it's a very simple concept
to wrap your head around.
Humanity has been using records for about
5,500 years since the time of Sumerian
tablets. So in that sense,
this is not something that new,
but it has two dimensions
that are big innovations.
So when you put those together,
it unlocks functionality that we
have never had access to before.
The first thing to know about blockchain
is that it is distributed. Uh,
it is stored in the case of Bitcoin
blockchain on thousands of computers all
over the world. All of those
computers contain an identical,
identical copy of the record.
And what that means is that
they're constantly checking
each other to ensure its
accuracy and integrity. Uh, so that's
one important dimension of this.
The second is that it is permanent.
Once a piece of data is entered into a
data block and walked into that chain,
hence the name, you can't change
it. You can update the information,
but you can never erase the information.
So if a government wants to wipe out the,
the contents of a blockchain,
it can't do it. Uh, if a company wants
to wipe out the contents of a blockchain,
it can't do it. They are designed to be
incredibly resilient and incredibly, uh,
secure.
Uh,
and those are very important
when it comes to this,
this permanence that we're talking about.
When you put those two pieces together,
uh, the distributed nature of the record
and the permanent nature of the record,
it provides the opportunity to do some
things that we've never been able to do
before.
It is an independent source of,
for any information that you put in,
you can validate that something was
created at the time you say it was created
because it's logged in the blockchain.
And again,
nobody can monkey with it once it's there.
Uh,
you can assure that a boat
has been tabulated correctly.
If it's hash to the blockchain, you
can ensure that a property record, uh,
has been registered in the way that
it's supposed to be registered.
It has the potential by virtue of
this independent distributed, uh,
and permanent functionality, uh, to
solve a lot of problems around trust.
A lot of problems around corruption and
a lot of problems around transparency.
And those are all big issues that we
are wrestling with in the world today.
And because of that,
I feel it's a very important technology
for all of us to hopefully put our arms
around.
I agree.
Um,
do you think there's any doubt at this
point that blockchain technology is going
to become mainstream?
That's a great question.
Uh,
I think blockchain technology today is
in very much the same place that the
Internet was in about 1993 or 1994.
Uh,
and what that means is that this
could go any number of directions.
There is no a fore ordained
course for the technology,
but the functionality is
incredibly important. And again,
the functionality enables us to do so
many things that we'd never been able to
do before, that the functionality probably
isn't going anywhere. Theoretically,
somebody could come along with a
technology that will provide that same
functionality in a way that is potentially
a little bit cheaper or potentially a
little bit more efficient.
So that could theoretically again
derail adoption of the technology. Uh,
but in terms of what it can
do that is here to stay.
And I would imagine, I would expect that
it will become a ubiquitous technology,
uh,
in the course of coming years.
Uh, so with your experience in
politics and civic and institution,
can you describe,
uh,
your vision for global
adoption of blockchain and
what are the key steps in this
transition
that,
that is a big question and we could
probably spend the better part of our time
here discussing that. Um, a
couple of things. First, Bitcoin,
which is the application of blockchain
that most people are familiar with.
And again,
I imagine it is a,
not a news announcement
to those in this room. Uh,
but blockchain was originally developed
as the rails to power bitcoin and has
since been adapted into a variety
of different applications. Um,
bitcoin is already gaining pretty
broad global adoption and eh,
the first place where you are likely to
see blockchain applications take hold a
is in financial technology.
IBM came out with a survey a little
while ago that estimated that in the next
three years,
65% of all big banks are
going to be using blockchain.
So this is a technology in that space,
certainly as it,
as it relates to payments as it relates
to moving money and financial assets
back and forth, uh, has kind of
already reached the tipping point.
That train has left the station. So
that's stage one. That's exciting.
There is again,
a misperception that this is something
that is going to happen soon in practice.
This is something that is
happening right now. Uh, so, uh,
don't anticipate that it's going to be
years and years before you see those use
cases rolling out.
The second piece of this will happen
when you see adoption and what I call a
intact or institutional technology.
Uh, some people call it Gov tech.
Uh,
but these are the entities that validate
the facts that make up kind of the base
layer of reality that we
all have to agree on. And,
and here I'm going to pause and kind of
zoom way back for a moment if you will
forgive me. Yaka uh, there was a,
another great, uh, toxic Google speaker,
a historian named Yuval Hariri who asked
an important question a couple of years
ago. He said, why are
humans in charge? Why,
why are we the ones that run the
planet and not fish or rang a tanks?
Because theoretically it could
be Jelly Fisher Orangutans.
And what he recognized is that humans
are able to do two things that other
species can't do. The first is
that we can cooperate flexibly. Uh,
and the second is that we
can cooperate at scale.
So if you look at other species,
you find some that can cooperate flexibly,
like wolves and dolphins,
you find some that can cooperate
at scale like bees or ants,
but nobody else can do
the two of those together.
The way that we are able to do that is
we come to a consensus on kind of a base
layer of reality, a certain set of facts
that everyone is willing to sign up for.
And once we do that,
we're able to go off and in many different
verticals pursue our own individual
agendas on the basis
of those common facts.
What blockchain is going to allow us to
do potentially is create a new form of
consensus around basic
facts. And that is if, again,
if we do it right,
uh,
a solution that has the potential
to supercharge collaboration,
to supercharge cooperation in ways that
we've never been able to work together
previously.
Um,
and so as you see institutions
that keep track of who owns what,
who voted for whom,
uh,
who owns which piece of property
start to move their activities on the
blockchain,
you're going to see a very big new chapter
in the history of human cooperation.
Uh, and, and that's
going to be really cool.
What happens at that stage I would
suggest is that we're likely to see the
emergence of business models that we find
it difficult to even conceive of right
now. But business models
that take advantage of, uh,
the tokenization of assets,
uh, where we take a,
anything that we have a chair, a car, uh,
I have kilowatt of energy and have the
ability to transfer that back and forth
seamlessly.
If you think about the last 20 years,
what you and others at Google had been
working on a is really facilitating the
frictionless peer to peer exchange of
information and what blockchains should
enable us to do,
uh,
is engaged in the frictionless
peer to peer exchange of assets.
Once we hit that tipping point,
a lot of exciting things are
going to happen really quickly.
I'll stop talking there. That's
a very long, complicated answer.
Okay.
Uh,
I want to ask specifically
about governments because
the ironman traditionally
are one of the, you know,
latest adopters of technology.
And how do you think a government might
adopt blockchain either as a currency or
for administration and vendor?
You think that might mean?
That's a another very good
question. Um, so two pieces. Uh,
first,
how will governments use blockchain?
I would suggest that the first
iterations of government, uh,
utilization of blockchain technology
will be focused on how you can provide an
added level of assurance
around data integrity. Uh,
and this is already happening.
A project that we have been heavily
involved in a is moving the country of
Georgia as land registry on a blockchain.
Why would you want to do this?
Why would you care about putting
a land registry on blockchain?
In many parts of the world,
if Jasmine has a nice piece of property
by the lake and I want it and my cousin
works for the land registry,
I go and talk to my cousin,
my cousin's signs that
property over to me.
And because the registry
controls the record,
there's nothing that you can do about it.
You are out of luck at that point. Uh,
and it would be nice to say
this is an isolated phenomenon.
This is not an isolated phenomenon.
This is something that happens
on a very regular basis.
So if you work in a country or live
in a country where people have those
concerns,
if you can take those registries and
move them into a format where even if
you've got a corrupt official
with access to the information,
they can't go in and wipe out the
evidence that it was Jasmine's property to
begin with.
That's a big deal.
And citizens are going to
sleep a lot better at night,
especially when it is a in conjunction
with something as important and
fundamental as your home. So those would
be the, the early iterations. And again,
that's already happening.
A Georgia system is active.
It has about 200,000 records
according to the World Bank.
It is now the number one system in
the world, uh, for land registration.
So we've seen good progress there.
A Dubai, his pledge, the by 2020,
they want all of their government,
uh,
transactions to be taking
place on blockchain.
Ukraine has committed to moving all of
their transactions on the blockchain and
we see many other countries around the
world that are starting to dabble in this,
in the United States.
We've worked over the last year with
about eight government agencies that are
investigating different use cases for
blockchain and starting to stand up their
own pilots. Uh, there's enormous
potential there. And again,
at a moment when we are facing a
real crisis of confidence of trust in
institutions,
this has the potential to be a very
valuable tool for governments who are, uh,
working desperately to Regaine and win
back some of the confidence of their
citizens.
Uh, what about the pushback
of the corrupt official?
It's like how have they overcome that?
Do people have the power
to overcome that pushback?
That's said very good question. Uh,
and you see kind of two dynamics.
There's some countries and you know,
I speak now as somebody who spent the
better part of the last decade working in
nations around the world that we're
struggling with issues of governance and
trying to get their democracies
to function properly. Uh,
there's some countries where the leaders
in charge don't want any transparency
and don't want any accountability.
And I would be very surprised if you
see many of those countries adopting
blockchain technology.
There is another pretty wide swath of
countries where people in charge actually
do want more accountability
and transparency,
but the systems they are working with
are so dysfunctional and so broken and so
corrupt that it's extremely difficult
to impose those solutions from on high.
Those are the cases where blockchain
could be pretty transformational. Uh,
and in some instances I think you're
going to get rigorous pushback from those
in the bureaucracy,
uh,
that are benefiting from the status quo
because once they recognize that it will
make it much more challenging
to engage in corruption,
they may be a little bit concerned.
But in other cases,
what we're finding is that this is,
uh,
a sufficiently large transformation that
even people on the wrong side of the
equation right now understand they're
better off supporting this and working to
build new,
more accountable and more transparent
business models and lives for themselves
on the other side. Uh, then
they are fighting this outright.
So I've actually been surprised and
impressed by the extent to which there
hasn't been more pushback at this
stage of the technology's adoption.
Yeah.
So Kyle,
these governments that are adopting or
government institutions that they're
adopting blockchain,
they typically create their own blog
chains or do they use existing ones?
Uh, yes is the answer. And that's
another exciting dimension of this.
When blockchain technology first emerged,
people thought there were only
two flavors of blockchain,
public blockchains like Bitcoin,
blockchain or the ethereum blockchain,
which run on computers all over the
world and anyone can set up a note and be
part of those networks or private
blockchains that are defined.
They exist within kind of a walled garden.
You can only set up a node on that
network if you're invited and have the
appropriate credentials.
What we're finding now is that some of
the most powerful functionality comes
when we actually layer blockchains.
And when you use public blockchains and
private blockchains in coordination,
uh, I'll give you an example of how
this is working. In the case of Georgia,
the Bitcoin blockchain does
a lot of things really well,
but it is not ideally suited to
processing big chunks of data.
So if you have a complicated
map of a property, some place,
it's going to be really tough to
store that in the Bitcoin blockchain.
So in this case, our technical
partner, the bit fury group,
developed a solution called Exxon him,
which takes a snapshot of the
registry, uh, every few minutes.
And Hash is that blockchain or
stores that a static snapshot, uh,
in a public blockchain.
So what it allows you to do is
design a solution that's bespoke.
You can get very high,
uh, transaction rates.
You can get really big data
blocks as part of this system. Uh,
you can do it exactly the
way you need to do it, uh,
but then you have the data integrity
and the security that comes with logging
that data are hashing that
data to a public blockchain.
And I think that's where a lot of the
public sector applications will eventually
end up, uh, is using this
layered approach, uh,
that anchors information
to a public blockchain, uh,
but actually stores the information
in a private blockchain,
uh, in, uh,
among current politicians
and government officials, uh,
especially in the US. What's their
current perception of blockchain?
No, that's a, it's an excellent question.
I have a good friend who spent a long
time working at the White House and after
she left the White House,
somebody came to her,
a former colleague who had gone on
to MIT, came to her and said, hey,
I really think you should get
involved in blockchain technology. Uh,
and her response was, uh, that's
criminal money and you're crazy.
And, uh, I think if you
had to be honest about it,
that is the perception of a lot of
folks in government right now. They,
they view a blockchain and bitcoin
and everything associated with it,
uh, as something that they probably
don't want to dabble with. Uh, and,
and this mutual friend of
ours said, well, you'll wrong.
Take some time to learn about it
and come back to me once you have a,
and you know,
she reached the conclusion that this had
the potential to be a transformational
tool for supporting good governance.
And I went through that same
process of realization. Uh,
and I think what we are are focused on
right now and a lot of our educational
efforts,
both with the global blockchain business
council and with the blockchain trust
accelerator,
is working with policy makers to help
them understand how they can use this tool
to solve public problems.
Uh, and you know,
what we've seen is a pretty
dramatic transformation.
I'll give you just one additional
anecdote in that department. Uh,
almost exactly a year ago,
may have been a year ago this week
I went into meet with the, uh,
president's staff at
the World Bank and said,
this is something that's really important,
uh,
this has the potential to dramatically
change the way you do business.
And I think you should spend some time
and energy understanding how this works.
And they looked at me and smiled and
said, you're adorable. That's really nice.
Uh,
we don't do early stage technology.
Come back and see us in five years
and we'll have a conversation.
And a about six months after that,
they gave me a call and asked me to
keynote the launch of the World Bank's new
blockchain lab. Uh, and in October
we cohosted with the World Bank, uh,
the first ever blockchain summit,
uh,
that they convened on the margins
of the World Bank's annual meetings.
So we are seeing that narrative play
out in institution after institution and
organization after organization.
And I think there's immense potential as
we try to help policy makers and others
with the capacity to deploy
these solutions at scale,
understand what can be done, uh, if
this technology is harnessed correctly.
So you mentioned the global luxury in
business council and the luxury infest
accelerator,
um,
in addition to promoting
blockchain, uh, in, uh,
among politicians,
uh,
what specifically these organizations
also do and are they related?
What's the connection between them?
Great question.
Um,
so these organizations both started out
of as series of conversations that we
had during a very difficult,
challenging business trip.
I took to Richard Branson's island in
the Caribbean and he hosts an annual
blockchain summit. And a while we
were there, we surveyed the landscape.
This was now about a year and a half ago,
and saw that there was an enormous
amount of investment and activity around
Fintech or financial technology
applications for blockchain,
far less was taking place in the
governance and social impact space.
And we wanted to solve that problem.
So we set up a partnership called the
blockchain trust accelerator that brings
together a number of different
communities and a number of different
organizations. Uh, first the, the
place that I worked at New America,
we are a civic incubator and think tank.
Uh,
our board is people like Eric Schmidt
who chaired our board for many years and
then David Brooks of the New
York Times. Uh, then we, uh,
pulled in one of the world's
largest blockchain companies,
the big fury group. Uh,
then we invited organizations that
work on solving public challenges.
The National Democratic Institute,
which is chaired by Madeline Albright
and the Rockefeller Foundation has since
joined us.
And together we work to identify
pilot projects in the social impact in
governance space that can benefit from
the application of blockchain technology.
And then we educate, build communities
around those solutions. So,
in addition to the Georgia
project that I mentioned earlier,
we've also worked to take,
uh,
the world's largest registry
of civil society organizations,
900,000 organizations
from around the world. Uh,
and move that registry,
uh, onto blockchain.
We've worked with partners in the UK who
are doing polling and public engagement,
uh, in, in the UK parliament, uh,
to help them build pilot
projects around blockchain.
And we have many more in the pipeline.
So that's the blockchain
trust accelerator.
We're always looking
for partners and talent.
Come talk to me afterwards or send me
a note if you'd like to work with us.
The global blockchain business council
emerged out of the World Economic Forum
meeting in Davos and it is a group of
leaders from about 40 countries who saw a
real need to shape the deployment of
this technology on a global Blake basis.
Uh, we bring together public sector
actors, policy, uh, thinkers,
uh,
and also a lot of very important partners
in the private sector to look at how
you can, uh, provide people
with the information they need,
especially c suite level leaders to
make good decisions around their use of
blockchain technology. How you
can build partnerships, uh,
that will harness this
technology successfully. Uh,
and how we can shape a
regulatory environment that's
going to be conducive to
hopefully capturing some of the value
that can't exist if we do this. Right.
Uh, so you mentioned, um,
uh, regulations, uh, what,
what current regulations and regulatory
frameworks already exist and what's
about to emerge?
That's a very important
and challenging question.
We're seeing two big approaches
in the United States.
Regulators had a adopted an attitude
that they're not going to regulate the
underlying technology.
What they are going to do is regulate
activity that occurs on the platform.
And they're going to do that largely
using existing tools. So if you are,
uh, for example, uh, issuing
securities using blockchain,
which is a thing, as some
of you may have heard, uh,
there has been a phenomenon called the
initial coin offering, which is a, a,
a mechanism for tokenizing, uh,
in some cases value in companies,
in some cases, other things, uh, and, uh,
raising funds on the basis
of those offerings. Uh,
then the sec is going to take a good hard
look at what you're doing and if they
determine that what you are doing a,
it looks like an initial public offering,
then they're probably going to come down
on you pretty hard and regulate you the
way they would, uh, an initial
public offering. In other instances,
we see countries that are looking at
the technology itself. Uh, and here,
China's an intriguing example.
There's been a great deal of interest
and enthusiasm on the part of Chinese
officials, uh, in the use of
blockchain technology. Uh,
I was in China earlier this year and
we were accepted or received by a,
I think,
seven government ministers,
a provincial governors and justice
of their supreme court. Uh,
and about 1500 corporate leaders.
So this is a technology that has
a very broad audience in China,
but there had been some concerns on the
part of Chinese authorities about the
underlying technology in part because
it does exist outside the realm of
government influence. It's not something
that governments can turn on or off.
If you think about this
in a European context,
the Europeans have a law that I'm sure
many of you have dealt with a that deals
with the right to be forgotten or
so called right to be forgotten.
You can't forget anything in blockchain.
It's technically impossible
to forget information in
blockchain. So there's some,
there's some new challenges that will
emerge at a regulatory level as we bring
blockchain solutions to scale.
Now
sending issue with blockchain is our
long transection processing times,
which I've sort of slowing
the amount of adoption.
There are a few proposed
solutions to this,
but nothing that's really gone mainstream.
Um,
are there any solutions that you're aware
of that are likely to, they come in?
So that's a great question.
Uh, as you point out,
technically there some pretty compelling
fixes that have been developed that
solved the problem of, of
long transaction types. Uh,
a former Googler took a lot of
those fixes and package them into a
cryptocurrency called light coin,
uh,
that has had a rather meteoric rise
in the last couple of weeks as well.
So we know that technically you can build
blockchains that will solve for these
challenges that have very high transaction
rates, uh, that, uh, facilitate, uh,
again,
as I indicated earlier,
larger blocks of data as part of each new
link in the chain that constitutes the
blockchain.
What we don't know yet is whether it
will be possible to push all of those
solutions or some of those solutions,
uh, into the Bitcoin blockchain,
which is at the moment experiencing
a fair amount of congestion, uh,
in the context of, uh, uh,
pretty extraordinary
increase in the valuation.
A big bitcoin over the
last couple of weeks. Uh,
and so I think there is
an open question there.
Bitcoin may turn out to be,
uh,
something that is used primarily as a
store of value and for very high value
transactions. And in that case it
probably won't matter too much. Um,
or if you want to make it mainstream,
you will have to adopt some of
these new solutions, uh, in,
in conjunction with the existing rails.
Uh,
and that is more of a political challenge,
a among the various data centers that,
uh,
operate the bitcoin
network, uh, because the,
the bitcoin network is maintained by a
decentralized group of entities that are
often referred to as minors,
although I think that's a really
weird and lousy name. Um, but the,
the entities that operate these data
centers ultimately have to come to
agreement on which of the solutions
they're willing to bring into the network.
And that will determine, uh,
I would suggest the likely,
uh, transaction, uh,
throughput that will be possible
in the network going forward.
It's also important to recognize
just one more point on this,
that if you had tried to run
youtube on the Internet in 1993,
it wouldn't have worked that well.
We would have had some serious
challenges in doing that. And again,
we're in 1993. Um, so there
will be, I'm pretty confident,
uh,
more and better solutions developed
for these challenges as the technology
matures.
Hopefully some of you in this room or
watching will be able to come up with
those fixes.
What about some of the other pitfalls
of, of blockchain? For example,
the relatively high power consumption,
a volatility,
forks and plates, risks
of mining, pool takeovers,
a et cetera.
Do you see any of these as a concern?
These are all the easy questions and you
just lumped them all together there. Um,
so let's, let's try to go through
those, uh, in, in some sequencing.
First power consumption. Right now, the
network does use a lot of power. Uh,
ironically that's one of the
things that makes it so secure.
If you wanted to hack that,
we only know really one way to
hack the bitcoin network, uh,
and that is to amass a computational
power that is equivalent to more than 51%
of all the computational
power in the network.
In order to do that right now,
it would take about as much
electricity as a medium sized country,
uh, uses to operate. So this is not an
easy thing to pull off. And again, I,
ironically, it's one of the reasons
that the network is so secure.
A lot of the responsible companies in
this space are using renewable energy, uh,
and they are running the
network off of clean hydro.
They're running the network off of
geothermal energy. But there are, uh,
some,
some important reasons to think about
what happens is this technology becomes
more ubiquitous.
I would view the electricity consumption
of the network at the moment,
less as a bug and more as a bounty,
a $200,000 bounty that's issued every
10 minutes on finding a efficient,
clean energy around the
world. Uh, and ironically,
the spreading popularity of
blockchain may be one of the, uh,
forcing mechanisms for encouraging
greater adoption of cheap,
clean energy. If we do it right,
there are questions there.
It's not a foregone conclusion,
but that's certainly one
direction that this could go. Um,
some of the other challenges that
you mentioned, uh, the, uh, issue of,
of what happens if there
are in the network, um,
that is a problem that I suggest will
be solved eventually with the maturation
of the technology.
Right now what can happen and has
happened on rare occasion is that if,
uh, someone who is part of the network
decides that they don't want to, uh,
run the dominant protocol anymore,
they can go off on their own and create
what's called a fork in the chain and,
and develop their own a new chain as
part of the bitcoin network where as part
of anyone else's network,
uh,
that doesn't wipe out the assets
that you have stored on the network.
Those assets, uh, continued
to exist on both networks. Uh,
but it does create a problem if
you're trying to keep track of things.
As the technology becomes more ubiquitous,
as the size of the network increases,
it will be harder and harder for any
actor to create a dominant alternative,
uh, to the main chain. Uh, and I
think that is, uh, you know, again,
something that we're
already seeing, uh, as,
as the technology moves forward and
as the valuation a Bitcoin increases,
uh, but it's something that we'll
want to keep an eye on going forward.
So it is a very volatile acid right now.
Uh,
certainly there are a lot of people
making a great deal of money off of that
volatility. So a, again, for some folks,
this is a feature rather than a bug. Uh,
we're seeing a couple of developments
that should help tamp down volatility in
time. The first is, uh, as
many of you likely heard today,
we saw the launch a bitcoin futures.
Historically futures have,
uh, a moderating effect on
prices and volatile assets.
So to the extent you're able
to create futures contracts,
that should limit the extent of, of
the volatility within the asset. Uh,
the second thing that I anticipate
will have an impact on volatility, uh,
is the spreading adoption
of the technology.
The more people that are
using it going forward, uh,
the less likely you are to have wild,
wild swings in the valuation of the asset.
Oh,
you've only talked about some of the
opportunities far building infrastructure
and apps. Do you have
anything else in mind? Uh,
that might be a particularly great idea.
So I can tell you some of the amazing
solutions that we're seeing come our way,
uh, at the blockchain trust accelerator
and in the global blockchain business
council and,
and some of these are just immensely
exciting at a number of different levels.
Uh, we were approached by
one firm recently that's
developed a blockchain based
mechanism for doing distributed power
generation in off-grid villages and
developing countries.
Why is blockchain relevant here?
How does this work?
You can now buy for about a hundred bucks
integrated systems that will combine a
solar panel, a battery, some light
bulbs, cell phone charger, and,
and the other pieces that you need
for basic electrical system, uh,
in a little hot in a rural
village someplace. Um, so that's,
that's pretty cool that we can do that.
The problem is that in these villages,
very few people have a hundred bucks that
they can throw at one of these systems.
And up until now,
there hasn't been any good mechanism
for financing the deployment of these
technologies,
these technologies at scale.
So what we're able to do with
blockchain now, uh, is create a fixed,
whereby you pay four,
$5 of electricity and you put that money
into a blockchain system and agent puts
that money into a blockchain system.
And then you get a text message and
then you put that text message, uh,
into the electrical system that's
been installed in your house.
And you get two months of
electricity, uh, for that $5,
which is a lot less than
you would spend on kerosene.
And it's a lot less than
you would spend on, on wood.
So really good solution for everyone.
And then in two months when the agent
comes back, you give him another $5,
they put that into the blockchain,
they send you another code,
you get another two months of electricity,
and eventually you're able
to pay off that system.
So that's one kind of micro example of
how we're seeing blockchain a deployed,
another really cool example, a
company called box Gov, which has, uh,
for those of you who do ventures,
some of the coolest unfunded tech, uh,
that I have yet encountered.
They figured out a way to scrape the
80% of all information produced by
governments that isn't available via a
Google search or any other search and
curate that and make it beautifully
visualize a bowl and you can sort it and
slice it and dice it a
thousand different ways.
They then are going to put that
information on a blockchain, a framework.
One of the issues that governments
all over the world experience and our
government unfortunately
is not immune to this,
is that when new folks come in and they
don't like information that is stored by
the government, they get rid of it. Uh,
we saw this earlier this year with
climate data that was stored by the
environmental protection
agency in the United States.
And there was an effort
to wipe out and on a race,
some very important climate data, uh,
that had been gathered by the EPA.
This is a solution for that and it,
it will enable you to have a very secure,
auditable record, uh, of,
uh, all information that's
produced by a government,
uh, and you know, again,
search it, visualize it,
do a lot of other cool things with it.
The last thing that I'll mention
involves the deployment of grants and
government funding or other public
resources went now the u s government,
every year issues $144
billion in improper payments,
$144 billion in improper payments.
That's money that goes out the door
because people haven't validated, uh, the,
uh,
the recipients on the other end,
they haven't checked to ensure
that the recipients are alive.
There are whole host of problems that
come into play and around the world right
now, corruption is about a three
point $6 trillion problem. Uh,
if you listen to the United
Nations that just, uh,
to translate it is about 5% of global GDP,
which even by Google
standards is a big number a,
and what you have the potential to do
with blockchain is create a system where
as money goes out the door, it's
tracked, you know, where it's going,
you can follow it.
It's visible to anyone on the network.
And we're seeing a host of different
actors developing solutions right now that
should enable unprecedented levels of
accountability and transparency in the way
that public resources are spent.
The biggest impact for this technology
could eventually come in emerging markets,
uh,
that may effectively skipped copper and
go straight to these next generation
systems for deploying financing,
uh, around the world and,
and deploying funds around the world. And
it could have a really profound impact,
not only in terms of attacking that
three point $6 trillion problem, uh,
of a official corruption,
uh,
but also in pushing
resources and investment into
geographies where right now
it's not flowing. Uh, and, and that's
an important thing for all of us.
Current trust in politics is at
an all time low, I think it is.
And uh, could chain how to
restore our trust in politics.
And then in specifically the, the, the
issues that we're dealing with, uh,
like people,
um,
believing that their representatives
don't have their interest at heart.
And in many cases they don't.
And like things like people not telling
the truth or there being multiple
versions of the truth. And, you
know, these are the big issues.
Absolutely. Um, a really
crucial challenge.
If you look at the data, uh, at
Davos this last year at Edelman,
the public relations company
releases something, uh,
each year for the last 17 years called
the trust barometer survey. And,
uh,
they got up,
Richard Edelman got up to release the
trust barometer this year and said,
we've never seen anything like this.
You know,
this is as bad as it's ever gotten
in every sector that we monitor,
we see cratering trust. Uh, if
you look at the Gallup data,
which goes back much further
to about 1973 there again,
we are at all time lows. So
this is in, in many respects,
the challenge of our time because again,
as we talked about earlier,
the story of humanity is a story
of collaboration based on trust.
And if that trust leaves, if you don't
have access to that trust anymore,
you're not going to be able to do all
the other cool things that we're able to
do.
So this is really foundational.
Blockchain could very
well be that solution. Uh,
certainly my hope that it is
going to that solution. Uh,
and we're trying to tackle this from
a couple of different dimensions. Uh,
the first is if you look at the,
the problem of fake news,
which it seems weird that something,
you know,
two years ago and nobody knew
what it is, is now ubiquitous. Um,
but this is a real issue.
Uh,
and I was asked to come
have a conversation with the
leadership of a very large
social media platform a little while ago
to discuss how blockchain could be used
to create a supply chain for information
that flows through their systems.
Uh, and an essence,
once you create a story,
once you create some news,
if you anchor that news in the
blockchain, uh, or in, in a blockchain,
you can do a couple of things.
You can validate where it came from.
You can validate when it
was originally posted,
which turns out to be very
important in many instances a,
and you can also point back to it so
that each time it's posted on a social
media platform, you'll know
whether it comes from a reliable,
trustworthy source that has issued a lot
of good stories in the past or whether
it comes from the fly by night operation
that is notorious for pumping out bad
data and bad information.
Uh,
so I think it could be very
valuable in that context.
We've also created at the
blockchain trust accelerator,
a working group to look at how
blockchain can be used in voting.
We have big problems around, uh, voting,
not because our current
system doesn't work so much,
but because people don't have confidence
in our current system. Uh, and in,
in some instances we do have shortcomings.
If you talk about overseas military,
uh,
in the United States,
they have a horrific mechanism
for casting their ballots,
which means that in many cases they're
giving up the anonymity of their vote, uh,
and or their vote isn't counted at all
because it comes in too late to make the
deadline for the election.
Uh,
so we're working to figure out how we
might be able to deploy building solutions
that will give them a chance to cast
their ballot in a trusted manner going
forward.
This combined with some of the
anticorruption functionality
that we talked about
earlier,
I hope is going to make it much easier
for citizens to have confidence in their
institutions
after every surgery of
price of cryptocurrencies.
People begin to think it's a
bubble and it's all going to crash.
A including right now,
um,
can in European can value of
cryptocurrencies continued to rise?
And is this still a good time to buy?
It's an interesting question. Um, I,
it's certainly can continue to rise,
uh,
and it could continue to rise pretty
dramatically depending on the assumptions
you use.
It's easy to come up with scenarios in
which the value of a single bitcoin,
uh,
is justifiable at $250,000.
It's easy to come up with scenarios,
which the value of a single bitcoin
is a justifiable at a valuation of $1
million.
Um,
it's also easy to come up with scenarios
in which the value is much less than
that. And so this could go any
number of directions. Uh, you know,
my, my advice would be, uh,
I think multifold the first is don't
invest so much that you're going to lose
sleep over it. Um, and you know,
that's, that's been what I've done.
It's cost me some money because
had I gotten an earlier,
I probably would've made more.
Uh,
but I have plenty of friends who have a
substantial portion of their net worth
tied up in cryptocurrency. And, uh, it is,
it is a challenging thing to have a
substantial portion of your net worth tied
up in cryptocurrency because of the
fluctuations in value. Uh, but again,
if you look at this basket of assets
as a new analog for gold and as a new
mechanism for conveying
value around the world,
there's vast potential there. Uh,
and I think it's very likely that a,
again,
as we see a broader range of
organizations coming to the table,
including,
but especially institutional investors
that are looking for assets that are what
we say, a, they're not
correlated to anything else. And,
and cryptocurrencies as a whole
aren't correlated to anything else,
which is a big advantage if you're
a big institutional investor.
Uh, there's a lot of potential
upside there. Uh, so we'll,
we'll see how this goes.
I think it's also important to invest
in those that are developing the,
the picks and shovels, uh, rather
than, uh, just the gold itself. So I,
I've tried to focus most of my
engagement now on companies rather than
currencies.
Thank you for the, uh, for
the informative answers.
So you have been talking
about transparency all the
way. So what about privacy?
Like, do I like to everyone in the world
to know how I spend my money on all my
private, you know, life. Um, how do we
balance this in the blockchain world?
It was a very important question.
And blockchains are actually really
good at keeping private information,
private and public information public.
Um,
the bitcoin network is not anonymous, so
some people think it's pseudo anonymous,
but you can structure blockchains in
ways that provide far higher levels of
security than virtually any
solution that's available today. Uh,
we're seeing some countries,
uh, latch on to this,
arguably the most advanced he government
in the world is Astonia and Astonia is
moving medical records on the blockchain
because they feel that it provides much
higher levels of accountability
and security and privacy. Uh,
then their existing solutions, and again,
their existing solutions are really,
really good.
Um,
because of the way that the network is
structured and the fact that all of the
nodes are constantly checking each other,
it's almost impossible to see information,
uh,
on a blockchain that shouldn't be
seen. Uh, it would require, again,
this massive investment of the
electricity in computational power. Uh,
in order to crack, uh,
one of the blocks of data.
So there's really great potential,
uh,
for the use of blockchain as
a tool for promoting privacy.
It's also important to recognize that
at least as it relates to financial
transactions, uh, in a public blockchain,
people can see what's
happening on those rails.
We could open up a browser right now
and you'd be able to see every single
transaction that's occurring
on the bitcoin blockchain.
So folks should keep in mind those two.
Again,
as we develop more advanced
blockchain solutions, uh,
it's going to be a very important tool
for guaranteeing the privacy of data.
Uh, but, uh, at least as
it's used for transactions,
folks shouldn't be under the illusion
that their information is a anonymous or
secure in that regard.
And forgive it,
forgive me if this is
a rudimentary question,
but from an ecosystem
perspective in the future,
may say five years down the line,
having an ecosystem in which you have a
number of blockchains versus maybe one
or two main ones in which
everybody can pile into.
Is there a preferable approach here or
will it not really matter? And you know,
per use case will dictate the,
the development of one main blockchain
or several smaller ones for interested
parties, so to speak. Very
important question. Uh, and again,
I would harken back to 1992,
1993 for an analog here.
What we saw at that time as that a lot
of companies and a lot of different
organizations started setting up these
very novel things called intranets that
many of us will recall.
And they said, well,
there's this weird space
called the Internet.
We're not sure that we want to be a part
of that yet, but we'll, we'll play, uh,
within our organization for a little
while and see how we like sharing
information using these new
rails within our organization.
And after a couple of years, everybody
said, wow, this is really cool.
But it's also kind of stupid that we
can't talk to our friends that work across
the street or do business with them.
Uh,
and so we're now going to ladder
up to the Internet. And you know,
you guys, I think know the
rest of that story. Uh,
my expectation is that we're going
to see something pretty similar, uh,
occur in the blockchain space.
There will be a lot of
different flavors early on. Uh,
we will see lots of analogs to intranet
being stood up and eventually those
solutions will come together and it'll
be very seamless for organizations to
work, uh, on blockchains
across different platforms.
Probably using one or two,
a big main spines as they're the
conduit for a lot of that interaction.
Uh, thank you for all the information.
Um, I just have one question.
You mentioned something about,
uh,
investing in the picks and shovels.
Could you talk a little bit more
about what exactly you mean? Yeah.
So some company,
some entities are using a
cryptocurrencies and, and that's great.
Cryptocurrencies as we've discussed,
I had the potential to be useful
for a lot of different things,
especially in countries that have bad
financial governance and where citizens
are looking for alternatives,
uh, in, in my mind,
what is more exciting even than that and
what has captured the imagination of a
lot of folks as the ability to use
blockchain as a vehicle for other
applications.
Uh,
and the tools that are going to be built
on top of blockchain or that harness
blockchain, uh, I think are going
to be every bit as valuable,
if not more so to humanity in
the long run. Uh, then, uh,
the cryptocurrencies that are kind
of the first killer app, uh, for, uh,
the technology that we're, we're, I
think all excited about right now.
Does that make sense?
Um,
you just mentioned how we
can use a blockchain to help
you hold governments more
accountable, but at the same time, we need
cooperation from governments, you know,
to give the original information. So,
in that push and pool, how would you,
how do you sort of foresee how to
use it as accountability mechanism?
You know, especially with the most
corrupt or entities or departments or,
you know, um, whichever areas,
great question.
Blockchain works best when
people want to be accountable.
When you have an organization that
wants to do things the right way,
that is willing to give good
data, uh, because frankly,
you're not doing anybody any favors
if you put bad data into a blockchain.
That's one of the key lessons that we've
learned in our work thus far as you
really don't want to deploy blockchain
in a setting where you don't have access
to good clean data.
Um,
so you need actors that are willing to,
uh,
willing to move toward a solution.
Uh, early in the process.
There are still going to be
some instances, for example, uh,
if you're in a situation where you have,
uh,
evidence of humanitarian
abuses or war crimes,
I can envision a scenario in the not
distant future where a reporter on the
ground in Syria or in DR Congo,
we'll be at the log video to block
chain and create an iron clad chain of
evidence that will be useful for
a future war crimes prosecutions.
Uh,
so you can easily come up with scenarios
in which the tool can be harnessed in
settings where there's bad governance,
uh,
but the most profound benefits are likely
going to occur in settings where you
have political leaders that want to
do the right thing and bureaucratic
bureaucracies and institutions that
don't have the capability for whatever
reason, uh, to deliver
accountability. And,
and hopefully in those instances
it can be pretty transformational.
So I'm going to think it's going to
start with good guys first and then
gradually progressed to the most corrupt
ones and they're going to be eventually
recurrence.
That's been the path thus far.
And what I would say on that point is
eventually, again, if we do this right,
the gravitational pull of being part
of these systems is going to be so
profound. The benefits of, uh,
being part of these networks will be so
profound that every government is going
to want to be a part of this. Uh,
because if you're not just like,
it's really hard to exist in
the 21st century if you're
not part of the Internet,
uh, it's going to be hard to exist if you
can't send assets back and forth using
these tools.
Or if you can't reliably and accountably
track some of the key vital information
watching this will be used to track.
I'm just trying to understand the specific
advantage that blockchain would give
in the example you used is a good one
that distributed solar in the developing
world.
I mean,
because those kinds of financing
schemes exist now pay as you go mobile
payments,
mobile money.
So what is the actual incremental benefit
of doing that in blockchain versus
what's already being done?
Well,
blockchain in,
in a whole host of settings in emerging
markets is going to allow for much
higher levels of confidence when it
comes to pushing resources into the field
and tracking impact.
Uh,
and so as a tool for impact investment
and in particular it could be really
transformational. What it
will allow us to do if, again,
if we build these systems right,
is set up enough data sensors and data
inputs that we have a very good idea,
uh, of what the outcomes are
associated with these investments. Um,
so for example,
if you are considering whether
to finance the shipment,
a lot of these batteries,
solar systems to small rural villages,
you need really good data on
which to base that financing.
You want to know exactly where the
systems are, how they're being used, uh,
the rates at which those
payments are being replenished.
And it's going to make it easier
for everyone to trust each other.
Especially in settings where there's a
low level of confidence in the data. Um,
the analog I might provide
is that if you and I, uh,
decided you want to build a house and
you want me to build it for you and I'm
going to hire some subcontractors.
If we decide at the outset that we're
all gonna use the same set of books for
that transaction,
for that project,
everyone's comfort level is going to
go way up because we can all see what's
happening. We all know where the money
is at every given at any given time, uh,
and you have confidence that nobody's
ripping you off. Uh, along the way.
That's what we should be able to do at
scale with blockchain deployments in
emerging market environments,
do you see quantum computing
as a existential threat
for blockchain technology?
That's a very important question.
Uh, no is the short answer.
The reason why is because there's a
lot of work underway to develop quantum
resistant blockchains.
Uh,
and these are watching is that will
be based on a quantum market texture,
will harness quantum architecture, uh,
in ways that make them extremely secure.
Now,
in the immediate term,
if somebody were to come up with a fully
functional quantum computer tomorrow
prior to the full maturation of quantum
resistant blockchain technology,
then it would be a challenge. Uh, but the,
the hope is that these two
will progress in parallel. Uh,
and ultimately you should be able to port
existing data onto quantum resistance
blockchains in the future.
I hate to Micah, um, I
had a question about, um,
I'm not quite exactly
sure how to express it,
but maybe you'll get the gist of my
question that like, um, if we depend on,
uh,
like organizations that want transparency
and want to be good actors to like use
blockchain, like it seems like it would
be a rather limiting because like,
we've already seen stuff,
like I feel like the American government
is pretty hostile to the idea of like
lots of, lots of economic activity going
to like Bitcoin for instance. Right?
Because they want to be able to control
things. They want to go to tax things,
that sort of thing. Right. Um,
when in inherently lead to
situations where like, um,
you'll, you'll like the only people who
will be willing to take the risk of going
through all the trouble to like go through
these things will be the people who
are doing things that are kind of shady,
right?
Because like if I wanted
to do something like,
like buy a book with Bitcoin right now,
it's like way more effort
than just using USD, right?
Like how do we overcome that thing if,
if cryptocurrencies ever actually going
to be useful, you know, in, in general,
one of the coolest things I
got to do in government, uh,
his work with the then secretary of state
on the first big speech that anybody
in the u s government had ever given
on the topic of Internet freedom.
And in that speech we made a
really important point. Uh,
this was back in when
I was a speech writer.
That technology itself is neutral,
but we're not and we have an obligation
to harness these technologies as best
we're able to benefit society.
Blockchain is no different in that regard.
It's got immense potential to do good
things as we've talked about today,
but it can also be misused in
a wide range of applications.
And we've seen a fair
amount of that already. Uh,
so I think the two sides of this,
the first is ironically,
even the u s government is pretty
enthusiastic about the potential for
blockchain technology because they
understand that again, done right.
This could be the end of friction.
Uh,
if you think of all the little nuisances
that make our lives more complicated
and expensive,
this if you carry it to which its logical
conclusion and spaces like identity
and a finance could wipe away
a lot of those obstacles that,
uh, you know, make our lives
a little bit cumbersome.
So they see the potential on a lot of
governments realize that potential. Uh,
ultimately it's up to those of us
who've taken the time to understand the
technology and that's still a
very small universe of people, uh,
to try to steer it in ways that it will
be used. Well. Um, but you know, the,
the point you make is, is
really important. We need to
get to a stage quickly, uh,
where we can demonstrate
real value for society.
And that's what we're working on. Happy
to discuss further as well. Good question.
Uh, so my question was, um,
mostly about bitcoin miners and the
reason they mined bitcoin is because it's
financially that's the incentive that
they get much of it kind of the end of it.
Um, as time goes on, the benefits of
mining bitcoin are going to decrease.
So how is this problem being soldered?
Um,
that's basically it.
Important question. Uh, so
the, the context on this,
which I imagine will be familiar to
most of you is that the reason this vast
network of data centers exists is because
about every 10 minutes as a new block
of information is locked in.
Uh,
the data center that does that work is
rewarded with 12 and a half bitcoin,
which now is $200,000
or something like that.
So it's a strong incentive
to secure the network. Uh,
the number of bitcoin that will be
awarded will decrease in time to a point
where,
you know,
out in the next century it dwindles to
almost not that there are transaction
fees on bitcoin transactions that should
compensate for much of that decline.
Um, the other thing is we are seeing
bitcoin become more and more valuable.
So even though the number of bitcoin
that will be awarded to the miners,
the data center operators will decrease
the value of those bitcoin at least if
the last couple of weeks are any
indication is likely to increase. Uh,
and so between those two factors,
the transaction fees and,
and the value increase,
uh,
there should be strong incentives to
continue securing the network for a very
long time to come.
Would a crash bring things to a halt
because it's no longer profitability?
Um, so long as people are using
the technology, uh, again,
the transaction fees are such, there
are good incentives at the moment, uh,
for the data centers to continue
doing what they're doing. Uh,
it's something that people will want
to continue paying attention to. Uh,
but for the time being, it has all the
makings of a very resilient network.
Alright. Yeah. Thank you so
much. This was extremely,
extremely interesting and
useful and informative.
I want to thank you again for
joining us and coming and yeah,
the best of luck with your
efforts. Um, spreading the word.
Thank you. It's, it's an
exciting space and, uh, you know,
for all of you here and watching both
for the blockchain trust accelerator and
the Global Blockchain Business Council,
uh,
we're always looking for great
partners and great challenge.
And hopefully we'll get a chance to
collaborate in some of these efforts down
the road.
[inaudible].